I'm like 3et away from my camera right
now okay so who's our versus we we're
streaming right now so wait are we yeah
well I just like I just hit the button
you son of a I know you son of a
scroll yes yes well I was trying to
capture okay s think about it quickly
because welcome to the weekly poll I'm
not even record hold on hold on hold on
stop freeze freeze freeze welcome to the
weekly
poll wow I'm Benny of the comic story in
that is s of TV little house that is Rob
of Marvel explained and that is Dave of
his own room this is the weekly Bowl
Dave when you have videos you know that
come up consistently I'll promote you
so yeah yeah whatever welcome everybody
wow this looks like crap it tells me I
should turn how do I turn off Windows
Arrow so I can record this better no
idea yeah I don't know the problems are
all on your right
now tech support we are not ization and
then you should be able to change the
theme from
there oh yeah yeah that's right I got to
do theme hold on a second s this is
giving you more time to think of a valid
fight yes
uh what would you guys thing we we
talked a little bit off camera about a
couple of options uh thoughts
gentlemen um
honestly I've just blew my screen up
yeah yeah um I mean I I don't let's I
mean okay we got to do something
interesting but something something
relatively basic like we've got to stick
we got to stay pretty simple with it so
while I do think that the star CRA
everything's black and
scary
well well I think the Star Wars Universe
versus the Marvel Universe would be
pretty fun like yes let's do it I don't
know I'm look this is on my channel and
I have to redo the intro again so we're
doing this okay hold on a second we
could limit it we could say that the
star Star Wars was in Marvel that way
it's like we don't have to worry about
the force or Vader no no hold I I got
this i got this i got this ready ready
okay
recording start recording is it gonna
record oh stop preview I'm previewing it
wasn't even recording anyway the wonders
of live streaming okay all right hold on
ready ready ready welcome to the weekly
pool I'm
Batman wow welcome to the weekly poll
pre-show I'm Benny of comic story and if
you're watching this on my channel then
you know exactly who I am that is s of
TV little house one of the most amazing
shows ever to give you the the view of
people who don't know what the stuff is
that is Rob of Marvel explained if you
want true actual like non- Cliff note
versions of stuff you got to go check
out Robin Marvel explain and that is
Dave of comics reviews he tells you what
you should be buying what you shouldn't
be buying and how to buy some of these
massive things but he doesn't make
videos so
anyway I couldn't give you a full free
plug just couldn't do it just could um
so this week on the pre-show we're
bringing back the versus series and
contrary to what Rob our judge wants we
are going to do Star Wars versus Marvel
to narrow that down Luke and his team
which will consist of Luke Han Solo Leia
C3PO R2D2 and I'm going to give you Boba
Fett Sal Boba Fett Boba Fett I would
take Chewbacca the W over Boba okay fine
Chewbacca the W over Boba Fett versus
the Guardians of the
Galaxy there you go all right that's
today's verses I'm going to start it off
by stating we've got an interdimensional
Rift that explodes it's always an
interdimensional and two spaceships
crash land on tatat tween tatat Twain
the big desert planet that I won't
pronounce they both crash land onto the
planet the Guardians walk out Star-Lord
whips out his tools starts jamming out
to some old school 80s music uh and
looks around while on the flip side on
the opposite side Luke and all of his
friends walk out of their ship and they
go
that was my
lightsaber a pretty
lame and the two of them look at each
other and goora goes you must be working
for Thanos you crash landed us and Luke
looks back at them and says You must be
working for the emperor because this
takes place between Empire Strikes Back
and return to the Jedi Luke's at full
power but we still have we still have a
threat that they're all up against okay
Empire like Shadows the Empire kind of
yeah yeah yeah so we're going to go with
that you know we'll give you the power
but we need a reason for them to all be
in Conflict I to right okay okay so the
Guardians are currently fighting Thanos
and they crash land you're going to go
fight the emperor and you crash land no
one has space travel we're on a desert
Planet there's no environmental to use
what are we gonna do s you go next okay
uh well who do I have do I have Star
Wars do I have Marvel who do you want I
guess I'll take Star Wars okay I know
more about it I think which is hard to
imagine but yeah uh all right
well okay okay just I had so much
momentum going you just killed me I know
I know and then I was like I'm very much
good I'm really good at that and putting
the brakes on any enthusiasm uh all
right I'm gonna oh I think that everyone
would hang me if I didn't say Han shoots
first there we go that's that's the only
real that's the only thing I really
wanted to hear was shot first on solo
whips out his Blaster Fires at uh the
big tree looking thing because he thinks
that's the PowerHouse of okay all right
and in standard Chris Pratt version of
Star-Lord fashion he's like whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa yo don't you know who I
am Han Solo does not care fires
again sing
[__] hits the jet boots because what he
does it all the time in the comics even
if he's not anywhere and just rockets
off dodging the bullet yelling I'm
starlord and gut goes I am garoot and
starts Whi ing his Vine arm towards the
uh the Jedi and all them okay so uh well
Luke I think will use the force to
adeptly avoid um groot's Vine attack and
uses his lightsaber to make quick work
of Groot because he knows that Groot is
a living being but he also knows that
groot's a threat and he's kind of a tree
person and Luke doesn't really seem to
have any regard for trees as evidenced
by his experience on
D he uh he he makes I I think he'd cut
brute into ribbons with that lightsaber
I don't think there's any defense
against Bruth arms gone oh yeah Rocka
raccoon looks at Gro and says oh stop
crying it'll grow back anyway it'll grow
back you big out the world's largest gun
you've ever
seen
yep um he just opens fire he fires
second but he fired bigger right fir
okay um I think that
let's say Luke uses the force I mean
this is going to be my response to
everything Luke uses the force and he uh
creates a uh protective shield over the
over the gang uh meanwhile I think uh
R2-D2 is gonna make his way towards
rocket because I think that's the fair
fight I think R2 versus you're sticking
Rocket Raccoon against a tin can Trash
Can rd2 has more personality than most
of the characters in uh
the new Star Wars prequels I will agree
with you there so I have The High Ground
anyway that's a I would I would I would
disagree with you guys on that one but
go ahead I'm just the Jud but R2 versus
you don't think R2 versus Rocket is a
good pairing it's not a fair fight I
think rocket rocket is intelligent so
R22 is going up against so rocket very
quickly starts blasting into rgt2 jumps
on top of him just starts ripping stuff
out saying you don't need this you don't
need this you don't need this I don't
know what this is and I'm going to reild
you into something useful yeah guess
rocket would repurpose R2 into something
really interesting that's too bad all
right well that's the end of
R2 um all right well then I'm gonna have
Leia uh fight Gamora that's really bad
yeah okay you what I'm really poor fight
to choose I mean like well Leia's like
Leia Leia knows uh how to fire a blaster
like she's really good withu Blaster she
has latent Force ability so I guess she
would also be able to I think maybe even
predict some of gamora's
moves no Rob Gamora just goes in there
and starts killing what do you think is
gonna happen you're the judge gamor I
mean gonna die Leia Leia's Leia can Leia
can sense the force but she's no Luke
Skywalker and Gamora would is is okay
now all right now now here's the
question though are we talking about
Guardians of the Galaxy the film gamor
or are we talking about Marvel Comics
okay film gamor then it probably be a
fair fight because like would absolutely
Massacre film she would she would walk
up to to Leia and pretty much rip her
arms
off like that's more of a chewy thing I
think that uh well all right all right
so then can we just say that Leia and
gamorra are now disposed of each other
they're off well they're they're
fighting I guess yeah because like they
really depowered Gamora in the movie so
yeah now I think the only that we really
need to pay attention here what would
most likely happen is that with Princess
Leia and gamor fighting that as they
fought of course they'd be stripping off
different portions of their clothing and
whatnot and then like Chewbacca and the
guys
even hold on I'm gonna play that scene
out for you because you know you no
don't play so gamor and Leia are going
at it and gamorra tears off Leia's
clothes and underneath is Slave Leia
outfit and then Leia starts tearing off
Gamora who's conveniently also wearing a
Slave Leia outfit because they were
actually on their way to a comic book
convention in space so anyway okay so
going from there of course so wait wait
they're both in the slave bikinis which
now distracts Han
Solo because because Han has never
actually seen her in the slave bikini
outfit right so Han Solo is now
distracted and disposed up as as
Star-Lord now comes back around still
blasting off slams into Han Solo
removing him from the fight ah all right
well I still think I've still I've still
I still have a I still have the Last
Jedi knight in existence up against uh
we've already I've already cut down
Groot we've got uh we've got Drax all
right um oh yeah I forgot I have Drax
draxx and wook let's go yeah I think
yeah I think Chewy versus Drax would be
a fight to the death um I think that
chewy I I Gotta Give it to chewy I think
Chewy would pull his arms out of his
sockets and beat him to death with them
probably I you know as much as I would
want to say Drax would be able to take
out chewy chewy has no problems using
multitude of weapons before Drax even
get true that's true chewy would
probably shoot him with his bow
Caster knock him onto the ground and
then just I mean like if you but dra
Drax cannot be defeated but I will admit
to unconscious he can be slowed down
like the Juggernaut you can you can slow
him down and I think that beating him
mercilessly I mean like I imagine that a
Savage wook In the Heat of the of the
fight would be not unlike a mountain
gorilla where it's just this hulking
heavy thing that just lays down blows
upon its opponents I mean like a wook is
really at the core it's a it's an
intelligent you know sensient being that
has Mastery over technology but it's
also a Savage uh monstrous creature I
mean look what it did to Lando in Cloud
City when he heard that Han might not
have survived the carbon freezing
process I mean like you know chew chew's
I think the Drax is going to lose out to
I don't I think this is another
situation of if I had comic book draas
oh yeah I could have won but having kind
of dumped down draxx in the movie I
think he would just keep walking towards
him without although he does that in the
comic too but he would just keep walking
towards him you are a very furry
creature you are very fur what is in
this
hair you would make we on a desert
Planet I recommend you remove your hair
I mean I mean this this guy bolt really
hurt this guy Lord key uh Lord K I'm not
even going to try to pronounce that last
part said that uh chewy would make a
good fur
coat yes Drax walks over to chewy and
he's like ah you'd make a good fur coat
come at me and chewy launches the
bowcaster blast racks in the chest
knocking him unconscious disposing him
from the fight oh yeah which leaves us
with starlord versus Luke yes I
automatically dispose of Han by making
him scar at boobies I mean that's
exactly what happened too yeah he took
down Han already so really is just Luke
and chewy versus Star-Lord and Rocket oh
yeah okay I still I still have rocket
okay so well then quickly quickly chewy
and Rocket just go into a gunfight oh
yeah no no it's definitely it's
definitely rocket versus chewy don't you
still have Han Solo just because he's
distracted well he was he was knocked
unconscious by somebody I can't right
not because starlord blasted in as he
was UNC not unconscious okay yeah we
agreed that he would be distracted for a
second giving time to hit him yeah
starlord has comparable weapons to Han
so I think that that's fair okay so
Star-Lord lands down starts throwing off
oneliner quips you know like oh Nifty
flashlight you know and stupid [__] like
that that he probably would have said
better if it was actually him
right and Luke Skywalker now are we
going Boy Scout gol Lucky Luke Skywalker
or this is Empire Strikes Back Luke
Skywalker this is you'll find I'm full
of surprises Luke Skywalker this is like
we should do we should do Post post
episodes four five and six Luke
Skywalker when he is possessed by xaron
and falls to the dark side Universe
let's
not because extended Universe has now
been completely from moov I think I
think that just at least INF like
choking gorian guards in Return of the
Jedi L Skywalker the kind of L Skywalker
that's like light dark whatever is long
as I can succeed I'm
fine he's the guy who pulled a blaster
on jab of the Hut what a Jedi thing to
do so you know I'm horribly outmatched
in this situation I'm sorry we're gonna
agree that I'm horribly outmatched in
this situation right now I think I think
okay iing and as roguish as starlord is
I think Luke Skywalker has got it okay
well no hold on hold on I have I have an
ace up my sleeve because we're going
movie Guardians and the judge has to
decide well it better be one hell of an
ace because I P out the infinity stone
what he open what what did what did
rocket make R2D2
into no but but Peter Quill Peter Quill
did have the power gem yep I said I have
the power gem now I wh that [__] out
what now judge what I don't know power
gem versus the force what do you say I
mean like that's an that's an even match
because the force doesn't give
you has the power but Power gem Yeah
well yeah we're gonna say it's right at
right before like this whole thing
happened right before they gave the
power J to the Nova Corp but I
still um I'd okay let just for the sake
of argument because at this point it
comes down to like hair splitting so I'd
say we'll just call it an even match and
say the force and the power gy are even
in terms of what they can do the power
gem just warps reality and reverses time
to before all this happened no power gem
can't do that power gem just makes you
like super strong oh well then no I'm
not say I'm not accepting that I go in
with the power gy and just start laying
waste to
Luke well the judge the judge will
rebuke your argument and uh say that
Luke Skywalker wins so I think Luke is
going to Lop off the hand that holds the
power gem I think rocket made a giant
magnet out of R2-D2 and he sucks Luke's
lightsaber away from him Dave is on my
side okay okay um and then Star-Lord
blast the heck out of Luke and he tries
to deflect it with the force uh but it's
just too much and one of the blasts gets
through and stuns Luke and that allows
Star-Lord to go in for the final
blow since he starlord he doesn't kill
him he just knocks him out yeah yeah
yeah okay I'm accepting Dave on my team
do you accept are sufficient for a
finale I think that's I think that is
sufficient all right I mean like Leia
you know she's still around but whatever
um all right yeah all right I I'll ad
and Gamora are still off fighting
without any close
on and so okay so then now that now that
the fight has been resolved they all sit
down pop open a beer and just watch Gora
and Leia fight it out and save offense
and watch and watch Flash Dance at the
same time yeah right so all right we
agree in the ending of this
aome yeah rocket repairs are
tod2 yeah and
what back as a baby dra wakes up it's
just like what's going on I enjoy this
Brew
yes okay um well then uh I guess we've
wrapped up this one a lot quicker than
expected but thank you guys if you
joined us for this week's verses um we
are doing this on a every other week
cycle now because the opposite week is
going to be a debate for TV little house
so your week this week was Star Wars
versus Guardians of the Galaxy to which
we agreed with a Little Help from Dave
even though he doesn't have a channel
no with a little and the comics review
Channel um he helped me win this one so
thank you Dave um and make sure you go
check out Sal over TV little house they
do great uh every uh videos every
Thursday and stuff sporadically
throughout the week Rob puts out videos
whenever Rob feels like making them
which is like eight times a week and
then he takes a break take a break and
Dave one day we'll make a third video
but make sure you go over to his channel
give him a subscription but if you are
watching this post afterwards on my
channel make sure you go check out
Marvel explain to see the full podcast
where what are we talking about today
Rob uh we're talking about Guardians of
the Galaxy finally thank God it's been
two weeks I've been dying to talk about
this
and turtles other tang and and Ninja
Turtles apparently and the Inhumans film
that is rumored to supposed to be
happening so oh wait wait and we also
have to discuss how Sal and I got April
Fool's prank four months after the April
Fool's prank yeah did you guys seriously
get by that because I thought you were
pranking me and then I told Rob about it
in the podcast so thank you everybody
over here at comic story and make check
out the main show over atpl I'll see you
guys next week oh my God okay do you
want me to reopen it or do you care uh
man I don't think they care in the chat
um well then real quick thank you for
joining us for the weekly poll today
we're going to be talking about a lot of
stuff it's going to be really fun all
right anyway as we were saying so let's
do this I'm G to open this one with what
exactly happen so my buddy one of
because I have I have a focus group
every one of my videos goes up to my
focus group first Rob knows about it
Dave knows about it s hates
it um but basically I have a focus group
that I send stuff out to and I they they
I don't know if they ever pranked I
never asked them but they sent me an
article stating that fox gave up the
rights to um whoa Fant fantastic billion
doll a ridiculous sum of money that
would never be able to make back right
1.8 billion doll a
movie and what ended up happening was I
fell for it and I started telling all of
my friends about it and one of my
friends is s and I'm like s so we were
talking about the New York comics on
thing and I'm like by the way and we
ended up talking for four hours about
how amazing this is going to be and the
direction they can take with this all
kinds of crazy
[__] yeah that was
uh and and then and then like s
apparently tweeted it out and then
someone's like dude this is an April
Fool's joke yeah somebody's like hey man
freaking four months late I was like oh
I'm an
[__] I actually think I saw it back
then but I forgot about it
entirely um a friend of mine actually I
told them I was I told my friends about
it I was like oh this great news and
they were like oh that's really cool and
a friend of mine uh saw my tweet at like
2 in the morning um where I was like I
got punked it's not real and she got
really mad but not at me at like at the
idea of April fools in general that what
it's become where it's basically Liars
day and it's like hey um the lesson that
you should extrapolate from this
experience is don't trust Joy like it's
not like this is not a rubber spider in
my cocktail this is like taking
something you really really want and
then telling you you get to have it and
then taking it away from you yeah and
that's not really a prank as much as it
is being a dick and so like I find that
the internet really doesn't know how to
pull a prank as much as they know how to
be
[__] that exact say this I do want
to say this in mind and Sal's defense we
even asked why is this not all over the
news yeah
and that's what I was saying like why
can't I find it elsewhere on Google
right so what we assumed had was it got
bumped off because of the Robin Williams
uh news yeah it was literally like he
tells me this like the the the following
day in the morning like after right and
like why isn't this all over Twitter and
everything I'm like dude I'm pretty sure
everyone just cared more about Robin
Williams no matter what like even if if
the president of the United States got
assassinated it would still be big in
the news even if the president of the
United States were assassinated W thanks
for putting us on the nsa's watch list
there Dave I appreciate it the X-Men
being for the record this part of the
podcast is on Marvel explained his name
is Robert
[Laughter]
Jefferson I Benny Potter of comics story
and had nothing to do with the quote um
and the quote of the assassination was
from David Howland of comics review s is
also completely innocent totally a you
have to believe me I'm so innocent no
matter what we're all still on the watch
list where is the video s you never
linked it so I don't have it I can't see
the let's face it we the internet we're
on the watch
list H let's face it we use the internet
we're on the watch list yeah that's true
I'm sorry Ben I'm looking oh there it is
I'm looking for the live video oh oh
sorry s we got to discuss you not s Rob
we got to discuss your your thumbnails
I'm tired of seeing just marvel all over
your channel why man it's awesome we
gotta come up with something better I
mean it looks cool and I
like you know it's a uniform all right
so that that that's the story of how Sal
and I got punked and spent four talking
about the awesome possibilities of Civil
War and galatis coming back to to the to
the yeah like it was just things that
made sense that were really exciting and
I really don't see them needing mutants
for civil war though because they really
weren't that involved no but they could
have had like but it would have been
cool to have I don't even care about
Civil War to be honest like Benny was
like yeah Civil War I'm like okay like
if they had got to do Civil War that's
fine I was more excited like man we're
gonna get see Wolverine and the Avengers
or we're gonna get to see like they can
finally just make Sky mutant and be done
with it and not worry about like the
Inhumans non crash that stupid movie The
only reason I brought up Civil War is
cuz in the fake report they stated Civil
War so I was like well we at least know
that's going to happen yeah exactly but
no so I I knew that like was it is it
rert Murdoch who owns Fox yeah he wasn't
just going to come out and be like yeah
we listen to our audience and we don't
want to make money on it anymore so like
so the heck with it we're just letting
Marvel have it back I know billion do it
was one by the way no was 1. no 1.8 per
movie for five I thought it was just 1.8
billion for the right by the way is
still it's still not bad considering uh
Disney bought Lucas for like four are
are you guys aware of the fact that
you're debating over a fake article the
amount of money the fake people decided
to pay for the fake movie rights hey I'm
just saying that's the reason I knew
that it wasn't real or yeah deep down I
was like no this is probably going to
turn out to be a rumor yeah it's
[__] hey let's let's move on talking
about Guardians of the Galaxy all right
all right hold on I'm gonna I'm gonna
give a little disclaim here because I'm
the guy that keeps us on track and all
kinds of stupid stuff um this is a
disclaimer we warned you guys a week ago
um now it's been two weeks we're going
to come back we're going to talk about
Guardians of the Galaxy this week um
spoilers Easter eggs all kinds of stuff
so if you still haven't seen it what is
wrong with you but anyway haven't seen
it take off now unless you don't care
okay this is we we we don't take off
still watch us just mute
us because don't
leave um yeah go ahead and mute us then
instead uh and uh what we'll have Dave
do the dance when we're done so you know
to unmute us for the next
discussion put up a paper like it's
okay um all right so I think we can all
universally agree here that the movie
was
amazing yeah all right that's it top all
right it was
strange strange Marvel film go on top of
this one it it was and in fact like to
me it didn't even feel like a Marvel
film no that's why I loved so much about
it no you're right it didn't feel at all
like a Marvel film I didn't at no point
that um I feel like the best part I
loved about it and we're not in the
spoiler Parts yet but the best part I
liked about it is they didn't try to
wrap it in they didn't they didn't like
out of the blue like oh by the way has
anyone heard of Iron Man a guy in a SPAC
suit down there oh one seeing what's
going on with the Hulk oh uh yeah I got
friends who are the Avengers down there
even the sequences on Earth we never
even heard about anything Stark No Iron
Man no nothing no there wasn't even like
a stupid article about like Howard Stark
like blah blah blah no they completely
made it separate but at the same time we
finally get to see how powerful the why
am I getting a phone call from New York
oh wait I know that is probably
um totally lost my turn of thought um
okay anyway uh yeah U we did get to see
the power of the gem which we haven't
seen yet no so you can take that and put
into other stuff well I mean like we saw
I mean apparently the red Vapor stuff
from Thor 2 was a is a
gem so like we got to see some of the
raw power of it used like we get to see
the Mind Gem and action in Avengers we
get to see like um that was the reality
gym in Thor 2 yeah but I think this this
is the first time that someone's just
flat out held it and we' that's true AED
it's a freaking gem yeah I think they
call them stones in the movie which I'm
like Infinity Stones yeah it's it's all
I mean like depending on what comic
you're talking about they're called the
Infinity Stones or the infinity gems it
it it like the the term just bounces
around like I think in uh in the what is
it um Infinity Quest I think they might
call him Infinity Stones or maybe they
call them Affinity gems I don't remember
right
okay it's an affinity glowing Orbee
thing yeah it's a gym that shines yep
that represents some Elemental force in
the but I was that's that's what I
that's what I really enjoyed about it
like you know granted I would like to
have seen the champion you know just
like flying around space like just
destroying stuff wielding this power Gem
and then just be like give me that you
know but um you know in the end I'm I'm
not that upset because I think it it all
just it all just tied in together so
well you know in all honesty I don't
really care how it is that Thanos gets
the gems as long as he get gets the gems
and then just like wipes out half the
universe but oh he's I don't want him to
wipe out the he's he's going to wipe out
the Nova cor they're already weak
they're keeping the gem so no Thanos is
GNA come down with just by himself see
the intro Guardians 2 the intro to
Guardians 2 is gonna be Thanos just
showing up being like Oh by the way this
wasn't supposed to happen as as per
Canon you're
dead I mean like I I think well I don't
even think I don't think Guardians of
the Galaxy 2 is have Thanos really I
think it's really going to be more like
I think Avengers 3 is going to open with
Thanos going to Asgard laying Siege to
it taking the red Vapor thing I think
he's gonna go to the novacore and
destroy it just this just opening
onslaught of Epic it'd be the best way
to open it up because because we all we
all expected it in Guardians we expected
it was gonna happen and they didn't and
the reason they didn't like go in that
direction is because if this bombed we
have a complete package movie yeah yep
no loose ends nothing really the only
loose end is who is star's dead yeah and
it was a smart move on Marvel to do that
because this was a huge gamble I mean
this was a movie that took off took a
took place out in space with a group
that was established in 2008 no one
really knew who Guardians of the Galaxy
was I seen the best quote on this Rob
that this is probably the most
successful the most the most expectedly
successful gamble ever oh yeah well I
mean yeah I mean you had to admit like
it would be it' be successful like I
knew it was going to be successful to a
degree
I didn't think it'd be as successful as
it's proven to be yeah like I don't
think people would come out and say this
movie's on par with Avengers it's just
that yeah when the first trailer came
out I I immediately thought Pluto Nash
and that it was going to bomb like I
thought like oh no they cannot pull off
a comedy sci-fi in outer space and have
it be good they totally can and then
like the the next few trailers built my
confidence a bit and obviously Marvel
hasn't made a mistake yet really so
everyone says that everyone is that's I
everyone to stop saying Marvel hasn't
made a mistake yet because Iron Man 2
was crap so wait wait hold on hold on
hold on it's not a bad movie but I'm GNA
chalk that up to Marvel's failure so we
can't have a failure it's all going to
be good now
so I yeah that's true I mean like what
was it Marvel hasn't lost money on
anything yet no like the story in Iron
Man 2 was pretty crappy compared to
everything else in the whole thing I
think I would I would I had more fun
watching Iron Man 2 than three well did
you guys see the interview with uh
Mickey R where he was talking about like
all the stuff involving Whiplash that
ended up on The Cutting Room floor he
was like the movie was supposed to have
a lot more to do with like Justin hammer
and Whiplash than the way it appeared to
be because like the the problem with the
movie was there was no like Central
narrative like there was no Central
Point it was just like well we've got
Justin Hammer who admittedly in the
comics is a really cool character and
yeah they were just kind of like well he
becomes a villain eventually yeah like a
full villain not just but he's always
been no but I mean like even just like
from like a business standpoint as an
opponent of Tony Stark like he was he
was just a cool character he was like
obadia stain so what Marvel did in the
film is they like took away this main
narrative like you got whiplash that
shows up and you've got this whole thing
I guess with Tony Stark and his dad and
it's like at no point can you point to
the movie and say this is the main focus
of the film it's just like there's like
all this stuff happening so well the
main focus of the film is Legacy like it
like it's a theme like the theme of the
movie is what is Stark's Legacy and he
like questions that he tries to force it
and then he winds up having like like
establishing one at the end like that's
the beginning middle and end of Iron Man
too it's just kind of like there's no
Central like who's the bad guy yeah like
is it Whiplash I guess but like what's
the what's the what's the real conflict
what's the central conflict of Iron Man
2 and it's like me like not much like
there's a guy who sucks trying to kill
him like whip like the fact that
Whiplash is on The Cutting Room floor is
great because Whiplash was boring and no
no come on Whiplash was not way better
than Whiplash this is the greatest
tangent we've ever had but today is the
week we finally get to talk about
Guardians and we're debating the villain
of the least liked Marvel movie ever so
here's here's one thing that I thought a
lot of people like didn't really pick up
on is I am glad that Marvel has made
Thanos as powerful as he is and the
reason why I say that is because when
Ron and the Accuser betrayed him with
the power gem Thanos was just like all
right whatever like there was there was
no concern he was just like he's like
all right all right who cares which I
thought was was awesome because if it
was supposed to be like oh my God what
am I gonna do now you know he would have
freed out but you know he was he was
just like all right whatever like I'll
just kill you I I have a question and
then this this is more for you Marvel
guys I've done my research on Thanos MH
does scroll have the wrinkly chin so
does Thanos I thought he was a separate
race he is there it's just a coincidence
yeah okay he's a Titan right
like a Titan from the Moon Titan Titan
part of Saturn yeah but he basically
just looks like a purple scroll if you
take yes he does but he's like he
apparently he's like an unnatural birth
like he's his brother is actually like
very pretty looking but like yeah he is
supposed he was just it's all like part
of the whole like Thanos grew up like
like the average nerd like he was weird
looking and he didn't have friends and
then he killed his mom and you know like
and then he he has this this thing where
he's in love with death and it's not
reciprocated but that came that came
later on that came after he
was that was after part of his character
like yeah yeah but the chin thing is
like yeah I was just curious because
it's very because I mean I've always
seen it the comics I always kind of
ignored it but it's very prominent in
there and we don't have Scrolls so I was
kind of like is this something we're
going to do you know
no no Thanos is in no way related to the
Scrolls I mean wouldn't that be funny
though if Marvel came out like after
original sin and just like Thanos has
been a scroll this whole time like super
mega scroll you know who would freak out
Jim Starin would he'd have a heart
attack yeah he'd probably just die in
his chair because I just read that
Thanos imperative or whatever it was
called God the Infinity the infinity
Revelation that's what I read I'm sorry
yes so
bad what it was so boring oh my God this
is not haven't read it yet the infinity
Revelation was so effing boring like
that was that was infity effing boring
no it man you guys you guys are just so
you guys are spoil Sports is what you
guys are all right back to Guardians of
the Galaxy yeah all right so so Ron and
the accuser all right I was actually
disappointed in Ron and the accuser the
guy was like a henchman I'm sure he
betrayed Thanos but what henchman
doesn't betray betray the person they
work for at some point in time
no what really irritates me about Ronin
though is in the books he has more of
his own agenda and goal and this one
they literally just made him a mass
murderer I just want to wipe it was very
nazish in my opinion yeah yeah he was he
really was like I'm going to show up and
kill people because I want to preserve
this old school way of life that hasn't
been in existence for a thousand years
like it's it's just like okay you know
like this is like this is dumb like Ron
and the accuser exist to pass judgment
on people not to like CT side don't
comment real quick just hold that
thought um Christopher fry says that all
this build up for Thanos and we finally
see him the dude never moves all right
keep
going never moves but uh no like it's
it's like like Ron of the accuser does
not run around and try to capture
infinity gems now I understand that the
movie takes place in a totally different
Universe than what we see in the comics
and that that I understand and that's
fine but I have a very hard time
believing that Ron and the accuser the
head of the accuser corpse the law
governing group within the cre society
which only answers to the Supreme
intelligence and the dude below them
below him and not even really them yeah
and not really them that he would say
well let's capture Infinity
Stones well it's not no who whoa hold on
hold on wasn't he didn't know he was
going for the stone no but once you knew
what it was he took it yeah well of
course dude yeah okay I'm gonna bring
the super powerful gem to this Super
Evil bad guy so that he can kill people
for me or I take it and now I can do
that but I'm saying like entire
motivation was just silly his entire to
BL up the other planet but yes I agree
it was very like generic villain
like yeah I think that worked perfectly
I I think that like you need him to be
very cut and dry like is like Rodan
theuz is a really interesting character
they did him great in Earth's Mightiest
Heroes the cartoon where like where like
Marvel's like you can't stop him like he
has all like he was sent to make to pass
judgment like he has accused you it's
over like I'm sorry he can't be beaten
and like that idea of the futility of
the character is really cool but I think
a little too complicated like while
Guardians of the Galaxy people think
like oh it's so like like what look at
all these crazy creatures like they all
look like people they all speak English
they're like there's just pink people
and blue people like they really did a
good job of making it look more
complicated than it was and just telling
a really fun story that really you could
set in like Japan or the west or on the
moon it didn't matter like it was just a
generic story that really worked well
with really rounded well-rounded
characters and like so you needed to De
complicate Ronin the accuser like it's
cool that they used him I don't know of
any other character you could have used
that you could tie in with like the cre
the novacore and Thanos that like would
have worked as well like instead of
making Roman the accuser like work as
like as he does as a comic book
character I think it's easier and I
think better for the movie we saw to
make him just the bad guy like you know
I mean he's just he has
very in the movie yeah and I agree with
you 100 they DEC complicated a lot of
stuff Gamora got DEC complicated too he
kidnapped me and I'm his daughter like
she pretty I mean like she's already
pretty uncomplicated yeah but they they
boiled it down to one sentence explains
her Drax they got rid of the whole thing
of him being a spirit inside of a body
God I was so disappointed by that they
were just like this is drax's race
drax's race is stupid they're big and
strong and he wants to go kill Ronin
because Ronan killed his guys and they
implied at the ending he's now after
Thanos because Thanos behind it all I
was so disappointed that they did that
and and because you know drax's
motivation is to kill Thanos awesome you
do that they I when he says like I have
to kill Ronin because he killed my
family I'm like okay so they changed it
fine yeah but then at the end they
shoehorn in he's like no he was actually
a puppet like if you're gonna do that
establish it early on so it doesn't feel
tacked on so feel like you know what I
hated about that though him saying that
at the ending was it honestly it gave
more intelligence to draas this is a guy
who didn't understand anything he was
the guy literally and now out of the
blue he's able to oh well behind all of
it it actually wasn't R it I actually
understand all of this now it's not that
he didn't understand Concepts he took
everything literally yeah yeah but his
but it it's not that he wasn't smart he
just didn't understand sarcasm well but
I mean but and I get what you're saying
about that but the whole DEC complicated
thing everyone got DEC complicated
except honestly except for Star-Lord
yeah even rocket raccoon's origin we
found out nothing more than he's an
experiment yeah well I mean like which
by the way I'm superficially he kind of
is like right but there's so much more
to it we de complicated it too he's just
the last of his kind he's an experiment
that's all but the scene where Marvel
explained that was like was so awesome
he's just like drunk and breaking down
he was like I've been experimented on
all that kind of stuff like that was so
cool there were feels like there were
feels all over that theater like when he
was freaking out yeah they were too emot
there were like at least two emotionally
raw scenes in that movie they both from
came from the cartoon
raccoon the only and real quick just
before we go to that because I do want
to talk about that but Groot was
completely uncomplicated to the point of
he was just a tree who's going to hit
things just a tree and yeah it's very
every yeah and every time that they they
even brought him up who's Groot oh he's
the raccoon's muscle and that was it but
but but I will say this like I think
it's a testament to how well groot's
character done and how well like the
writing was for Rocket Raccoon because
for a tree that walks around and says I
am Groot the entire time he had amazing
character
development like I like I felt bad like
I was I was like oh my God like groot's
gonna die and I was like this is like
this is awful I love Groot he just that
was one of the that was one of the best
scenes too at the ending yeah that was
speaking of emotionally charged scenes
I'm gonna go with a third one well I
guess I guess you could chock that both
of to Rocky R because most of them was
him being upset about everything yeah
yeah yeah like at the end I almost like
I I felt myself tearing up but like it
the the whole movie was like that where
they would they would build just enough
tension where you think oh man this is
getting serious and then they would just
completely flat out like nope this funny
thing is gonna happen yeah and you're
like
oh Guardians of the Galaxy oh you so
you're so
Conny um no and but going on the
emotionally charge scenes you're right
it was funny because the only other
scene that even hinted at getting close
to that was the whole Gamora and
Star-Lord thing where it look like
they're going to kiss and then she goes
and kills them like I know you rumor
you're like oh that's not a mus charge
that worked that worked well I was
really glad because like in the trailer
there was a shot of like them almost
kissing and I was like oh man don't link
them up don't don't link anybody like
why do we need to sexualize Gamora at
all like I noticed they cut a shot from
her in the trailer where she's like
getting undressed like it's in the trail
but not in the movie like I notice that
she's taking off her clothes and they
just didn't show that I'm like yes like
thank you for not dirty my mind now I'm
trying to think of what a naked gamorra
would look like and that doesn't look
good in my head I mean they they ask
that like they asked always aldana about
that and she said that like she just
wanted teenage boys to like her in the
movie uhuh like she just wanted teenage
boys to like her character so like
that's why they they like over
sexualized her and then like toned her
down in terms of
just like being a formidable character
in the film which at least from what I
understand in the interview that's what
she had said which was kind of
disappointing because I was like you
don't want to be like a a strong female
lead you just want to be like a hot
chick okay I don't care about what Zoe
Selana thinks so I'm really happy that
we have what else was she in she was in
something else she was in Star Wars or
Star Trek that was she's also ntii and
Avatar she's no Jake Sully she's that
one IC man says that he's more
disappointed that Ronin has been killed
because they can't expand upon him now
oh he'll be back yeah that that no one
says dead in a com where's his body
where's his body did they bury it was
totally incinerated but I mean they'll
use the reality gy and bring him back or
something all all had to do is like what
they with like the Red Skull and stuff
oh he's locked in this other Universe oh
wait I just I just thought of Avengers 3
what the plot is going to
be Thanos unlocks all these guys they've
locked away with the gem I mean lock
them in the Kil just throw them in that
interdimensional prison or Whatever It
Is On The Fringe Fringe edges of space
what was the uh what's the gem I think
it's the Space Gem that's in the cube I
think that's what they're trying to say
with with the with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is that like yeah like uh like
Kevin space is it Fage or [__] or how do
you pronounce how do you pronounce
Kevin's I think it's feige feige oh okay
yeah Kevin feige okay well that or F I'm
pronouncing it like 100% wrong but in
any event like yeah they they
specifically said that the COS The
Cosmic Cube was one of the Infinity
Stones so um so there's like all right
do what which is all right like fine
they need to do that but my point is
maybe red skull is in the gem like
because it opens up like he could be in
the gemm he could beonin I mean maybe
there's a whole Infinity Universe they
all get ped over and then there's
incursions and the new Avengers go in
and stop the infinity incursions and oh
no wait no we're not doing no no
incursions well the one thing you got to
also remember too is that there are
there are tons of of uh Cosmic cubes out
there like in the comics there are so
many Cosmic cubes like cubic is the
result of a Cosmic Cube and he could
make himself the size of a universe so
yeah I mean beyonder used to be a Cosmic
Cube yeah like there's there's all kinds
of like Cosmic cubes out there so um
it's entirely possible that the Red
Skull has been stuck in a Cosmic Cube
but I don't think we're going to see The
Red Skull again because Hugo weaving say
he doesn't want to come back and do Red
Skull anymore Al he doesn't need to do
that brings back Red Skull Abomination
the leader and Mandarin as his henchman
oh my God that be the Mandarin the
Mandarin would be like the weakest
character there you know they've implied
that there is a real Mandarin behind all
yeah I know I know that well from what I
understand what they're saying is that
either sir Ben Kingsley will become the
Mandarin or like the actual Mandarin
will show up yeah I've read that in
multiple places they basically have
written out a way to give us the real
one not which I'm glad to I'm glad to
see it because I was so pissed when sbin
Kingsley was just like hey I'm an actor
turned out you're right I'm so pissed
off that they didn't use the hor
horribly horribly racist villain and
Iron Man lore it's not dude it's not a
racist villain man he's just he's a guy
that has the has 10 Rings dude people
would have looked past that and said
this guy's pretty B dude he's dude he
can he can he can punch through Iron
Man's armor with his bare hands out and
felt that it was offensive that we
didn't have a Japanese Shredder yeah
okay that's Ninja Turtles and hold on
there wasn't a Japanese Shredder Ninja
Turtles originally there wasn't and you
can see in the movie where they were
kind of implying that it wouldn't have
been him and they kind of shoehorned in
oh the the such such they they they do
I'm not spoiling anything by the way
it's in the first 10 minutes you find
out that there is a shredder like yeah
and originally there wasn't a shredder
it was going to be the this other
character who's a villain who was going
to be the shredder yeah oh okay well
that's um did anybody else feel like by
the way Captain America 2 the Winter
Soldier awesome movie wouldn't change a
thing oh but who else was expecting
cap to face off against Robert Redford
and to have him rip his face off and
have him reveal that he was been the Red
Skull Bol I was so hoping that was gonna
happen I was so hoping that was gonna
happen and I was so disappointed oh well
I mean like and the fact is like it
actually made it less silly and comic
Booky that it was just a jerk like f
just some guy who was assho wouldn't it
have been awesome if he was just like
you kids in your
dog so that would have been so cool Nick
Fury walks in and he's all like cap you
know the mystery's been solved right
it's actually the red schull from World
War II pretending to be Robert Redford
yeah H yeah yeah I don't know B tied up
like this and Scarlet Witch not Scarlet
Witcher the black widow walk over and
just rip his mask off and he'll be like
I would have gotten away with it two if
it wasn't for you
Don you meddling kids um no I I wasup
dude Captain America I was so hoping
that that was but see like like it was
with Guardians of the Galaxy like I was
hoping that
when I don't know why they didn't do
this but when Ron and the accuser had
the power Gem and was like just like
tearing into people that Thanos was
going to show up at the very end and
just be like give me that gy and just
take it away
from I know why I because if they did
that you would have had the massive
Cliffhanger and we would need a sequel
yep by not by doing what they've done
now Nova cor which if you I me spoilers
but if you've read the comics they they
don't survive yeah we all know as comic
book fans where this could go as a movie
oh the Space Police have got the gem
everything wrapped up and nice and good
to go you could literally open the next
movie with Thanos just blowing up the
planet and taking it and starlord
reports no has just been destroyed the
Stone's been taken just like s set up
like you know he he has the ability to
go through and get the Gem from the Nova
cor uh take the the Red Mist from from
Asgard and just do a complete like sweep
of all these cultures that have been
developed he can also go and really set
himself up as like a really overpowered
like villain character in the third
Avengers yeah it allows him to go
through all the last couple of movies
and remind you about them without
actually showing you them like you know
what I mean like he gets to go through
Thor it could literally be the opening
credits yeah it could just be a musical
montage where we just see stos walk over
and he just does something along the
lines of I'm that's it I know where all
the gems are and then we just the
credits roll and we have like epic music
and you just see him walking in
literally showing his power of just
taking it yep and every and he takes
every gem but the last one which is on
earth right and it establishes that
Thanos is an Unstoppable force with all
these gems without having to show him
like kill people like you know like he
we don't have to have him explain that
he's powerful or have some character
show up and go like hey watch out Thanos
he's really powerful oh this is going to
be a real bad fight you could even do
that though see the opening intro could
be him getting the one from the Nova cor
starlord gets word of that goes down and
tells the Avengers about it then we cut
to a scene he's getting the one from Red
Mist The Avengers are now preparing what
do we do about this crazy awesome guy we
need to pull in more Avengers go get
that new guy the WASP go get the falcon
go get Spider-Man because we're totally
going to buy them from Sony go get
everybody they start setting up this
amazing like Avengers force with the
Guardians of the Galaxy then Thanos
shows up on the Earth takes the Cosmic
Cube oh no then we got Ultron ultron's
been resed and you know we got Ultron
and we got Red Skull and we got
Abomination and we got the leader and
then the real Mandarin shows up and says
I planned all of this and I just made
the greatest movie ever yeah but you're
you're forgetting one very important
person that was established to us and
Guardians of the Galaxy oh God Adam
Warlock Adam
Warlock they could easily next movie go
that cocoon had a giant bug in it Adam
warlock's going to be in three movies no
that that cocoon is Adam warlock I know
and and the reason why I know is because
James gun has said that was Adam
warlock's cocoon yep doesn't matter if
it cocon doesn't mean get name next
thing you've established almost nothing
with him and better yet I can even work
him into my whole thing so the reason
that starlord finds out about Thanos
Adam Warlock warns him and then Adam
Warlock with the Guardians goes to Earth
and the collection has been blown up so
like the explosion could have incubated
Adam Warlock in hatching during that
movie yeah I mean Adam Warlock is is
like pure like for the most part like
pure power so that usually that usually
is the case but um but that's that's why
I am man I'm so excited that because
that's that's the one thing I was hoping
for despite all the stuff that I'd seen
the quazar bands because honestly I
don't I don't care if we see wle vaugh
like I don't care about quaz about
Richard Ryder that would have been
awesome Richard Richard Ryder would have
been okay but I want to see I would have
even taken I would have Phan as Richard
Ryder would have been awesome that would
have been awesome yeah but I never
happening we can talk about you know
them casting like Zack Efron as [__]
Sam what why is it never happening no
Sam could be great dude I could totally
see Zack is not gonna do it he's just
like he if he was gonna do it he would
have done it they said like they were
saying he's like I'm not doing Richard
Ryder I'm not doing Nova like I don't
know like I know that they were they
were thinking about doing a Nova movie
and the fact they're doing an EV an
Inhumans movie I think they're doing Sam
though is the problem I don't think
they're doing Richard rer yeah they
won't do Richard Ryder no they're hyping
up way too much in every other media why
would we out of the blue go oh by the
way here's Richard Ryder even though
Richard Ryder is currently being hyped
up in the comics as like a big badass
villain that's what I'm saying like
they're bringing Richard Ryder back and
they're like hey here's how
he yeah yeah but the fact that he's
coming back I think is is like that's
that's what I'm excited to see I mean
not is a good guy no but but keep in
mind I mean Adam Warlock was a bad guy
too when he was the Magus which is
something now that I think about it I
really hope they do if they bring Adam
Warlock into the fry I I want to see I
don't think they will because what
they've proven what has been proven with
every movie up to this point is if the
history is overly convoluted we ditch it
they don't do it or they change it they
ditch they ditch all the overly you have
if we were to get Adam Warlock as a good
guy or bad guy he would either be a good
guy or bad guy he wouldn't flip sides he
would be the maggus or he would be
Warlock and we would deal with him
directly like that and we would get none
of his history other than this is the
guy who protects the gems or something
like that but but what I'm saying is you
I mean we've already got everything we
need to expl playing the mag it's like
we've got the soul gim you've got Adam
Warlock I mean that's all you need no
but but if it I I this is exactly how
they've been writing stuff up honestly
and it's I kind of I've been watching a
lot of these movies lately and I've been
kind of figuring this stuff out and
honestly it's one of the reasons the way
I do my videos 10 minutes they almost
they basically take all of the history
of a superhero and they Cliff note the
hell out of it and if it it has to be
explained into two to three minutes yeah
if it can't they don't touch it just
look at what happened to Drax drax's
current explanation is a two-minute
explanation his old one would have been
like half the freaking
movie well I don't think so I mean they
could have done it pretty fast I mean
they could have said but then you have
people asking way too many questions you
you need somebody to be able to walk
away and not have questions well that's
that's that's why see that's the problem
that you have when you take a gamble
with a movie like Guardians of the
Galaxy because you're 100% right when
you said earlier that with the way the
movie was done the Way It Was Written
that it's a self-contained story so if
it had flop Marvel would never have to
reference it again but because it's so
successful like now we're asking
question like okay why didn't Thanos
take the power gy away from Ron and the
accuser why don't we learn that uh that
dra is actually Arthur Douglas a human
from the planet Earth like why don't we
learn these things like why don't we
under like why aren't they because it
can't work honestly we we can even look
back at other superheroes look at the
Captain America Two movies they took a
60-year history and boiled it down to
Captain America is a super soldier who
has a friend named Bucky Captain America
got frozen Bucky got turned into an
assassin Bucky is now fighting against
Captain America in three sentences I
just explained the entire Captain
America Marvel universe history that's
true that is true now if we were to sit
down and go over the legistics of the
actual comic story does anyone have six
hours no now for Captain America that is
true now for Captain America I mean
honestly honestly the Tony Stark
alcoholism is something that drop that
they that is a huge thing in the comic
books one of the defining elements of
the Tony star character they still
reference it in the comics and it's one
of the best story arcs out there right
alongside like you know the whole Green
Arrow sidekick getting heroin addiction
um and we we boiled that down to he just
had a drinking issue during one party
yeah basically which was disappointing
right so I I totally do not see them
doing anything convoluted and if we get
Adam Warlock just like they did with the
Guardians it's not going to be the one
you want I'll tell you that right now
see that that's that's what I'm really
GNA because I don't want to see I don't
want to see you know Adam Warlock show
up is like Captain Planet kind of guy
you know for the universe you know and
it's like well with your your combined
you know I am Adam Warlock you know like
I just warlock a hero I don't want to
see some stupid thing you know where he
shows up I mean I want to see Adam
Warlock from the comics the Jesus Christ
you know Messianic kind of character
who's like I'm here to save you know
everybody from dying and here to
organize you know Cosmic entities
abstracts alongside you know super
powerful people and we're all going to
try to get together and stop Thanos and
fail in the process like you know I just
I want to see like that version of Adam
Warlock I think that's what's so
brilliant about the Cinematic Universe
is comic book people assume these things
happen and they they allow the the
viewer to assume that those things
happen without conflicting with it at
all yeah yeah but they don't explain
it because normal people that go to see
a movie aren't going to want to see an
hour of Adam Warlock development or like
the
Destroyer Rob everyone watching this I'm
I'm requesting funding so that Rob can
make a fan film explaining Adam Warlock
Rob will be Adam Warlock he will also be
starring as mad Jim Jaspers yes I will
Mad Jim Jaspers versus Adam Warlock who
will win you it'll be like one of those
Nutty Professor things where you're just
every role in the movie I mean but but
but see like in all seriousness though
like like here's the thing you know in
the comic books Adam Warlock one of
course he plays like a messiah kind of
character he only shows up when things
are really bad usually involving Thanos
and then pretty much like saves the
universe like when Thanos captures the
heart of the universe and wipes
everything out I think I think they'll
use Adam Warlock as The Watcher role see
I I don't want to see that happen I want
to see Adam Warlock show up you know and
and to say look like like you guys are
basically lost without me being able to
guide you which is exactly the case you
know and him band together with Gamora
and I don't know if they'll introduce
this troll I don't care about pip pip
was a stupid little troll who smokes
cigars in human form yeah I I don't I
don't care about pip but I want to see
them introduce like like real a really
good version of Adam War he doesn't
necessarily have to be a comic book
version like he doesn't have to be te on
teetering on the Edge of Insanity where
he becomes a bad guy and leads The
Universal Church of truth but I want to
see like Adam Warlock as like the
character for the most part that we see
in the comics the leader the uh the guy
that organizes the infinity watch you
know stuff like that like I want to see
that version of Adam Warlock in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe yeah whether
we'll see that or not I don't know but
it's going to be like draxx it's going
to be explain okay here's your challenge
you have five sentences to give me Adam
warlock's
origin and that'll probably be what they
use yep five sentences to give you Adam
War well they can't do it because it
involves a Fantastic Four no no you have
to drop it then so in five sentences
explain his
origin first appeared Adam Warlock first
appeared in a Thor Comic so they have
ADD moreal hold on what what they didn't
first appear in a Thor Comic did he I
thought he first appeared in the fantas
I just want to let you guys a side not I
just want to let you know a side note
real quick I looked this up because he
he was making the joke about the Captain
Planet Affinity gems and I was going to
sing along with them going with soul
time space mind reality power and did
you know that there is two extra gems
that they have not mentioned or
referenced uh the ego Gem and the Rhythm
gem the Rhythm gem theem no H has
control there's a rhythm gem in the
Marvel Superhero Squad univers ierse it
is the seventh Rhythm gem used by Loki
that makes sense and it's pink oddly
enough Loki's competing on Dancing with
the galactic Stars
yeah I need that Rhythm G I need to know
what I'm doing I was
wrong yeah just so you know Rob uh if a
character's origin originates with any
of the characters that fox or Sony owns
they own that character yeah okay so he
would have had to originate in one of
the
Marvel books that that Marvel owns the
rights to
he 66 D 1967 yeah I thought he appear
fantastic he appeared in Fantastic 4 I'm
sorry damn it I guess we will never see
Adam Warlock then it really depends
though because there are certain
exceptions here and there too I mean Fox
didn't know who Adam Warlock was they
could just say well we're going to keep
Adam Warlock and fox is like okay I mean
we don't know who that that is who cares
right well the think is going on with
with this thing is um if a character
first off the character is popular like
Wolverine even though he's been solo Oh
well he's technically an X-Man so we get
to use Wolverine you know it's that kind
of deal like with the Spider-Man they're
like oh we can use Venom and Spider-Man
because a spider girl because they're
they're a spider family but then you get
things like the the big debate has
always come into and I think this is
where the problem with Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver came into yeah they may have
started in one or two issues of a
different book but they've become such a
staple and everything else and that's
that's the issue with Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver has come in because yeah
technically they're mutants and X-Men
but they haven't been technically in a
mutant book in a very long time the only
real tie and only time we ever see them
in a mutant book at this point is when
the Avengers need to go against Magneto
yeah yeah but but see here's here's the
thing though
like no no IC man it is totally Canon I
don't care if it's chiby little short
versions they said there's a rhythm gem
that means that there is a dance gem out
there icem man is telling me it's a kid
show I want to see the dance Jam show up
in the universe I never I never watched
the Superhero Squad Show so I don't I
don't know like I just didn't see it at
all interesting to me I mean I was I was
like but now that I know that was a
dance gem I just want to see Thanos when
he was collecting the infinity gems was
just like I don't I don't need to dance
but see like like here's the other thing
though like like for examp wait wait
wait hold on hold on technically we
could have easily had the Rhythm gem
because at the end of Guardians of the
Galaxy Star-Lord challenges Ronan Ronan
that guy to a dance off that's true he
he he does have and he he should have
easily been like you may have the power
gem I got the Rhythm
gem I mean he introduced Kevin Bacon to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe Kevin
Bacon's probably Kevin Bacon's probably
the one above all in the Marvel
Cinematic
Universe oh no but uh but no like like
here's here's the thing so like I mean
there the way they're the kind of
characters they're introducing we could
really see some cool stuff like for
example Infinity conquests Ultron and
the fa links versus everybody in the
universe like Ultron takes over the body
of Adam Warlock I mean you know you
you've got Thanos you know who uh
honestly honestly Rob I think we need to
move on from Adam Warlock you're very
you're very you're very fixated on a
like millisecond Easter there was more
of an Easter egg with Howard the Duck
than Adam
Warlock people weren't paying attention
man it was a single scene and while I
agree we're probably going to get out of
Morlock you could discuss this for 4
hours why don't we discuss the movie
that's currently out I disc
that before we go on to continuing the
discussion I have no idea how you made a
25 minute long video on how or the do
yeah I'm gon I Pro you good
sir I was thinking about that I was like
am I gonna be able to make a 25 minute
video about Howard the Duck and then I
started to started to do it and I was
like yeah I could make a 20 video Howard
the like it's like I can I can like 25
minutes was a good number because by the
time that 25 minutes came to an end it's
like okay this is pretty much the end of
Howard the Duck like the controversy
surrounding Howard the Duck is more
interesting than the Howard than like
Howard the Duck in the
comics I want to give you props to that
because s did 30 minutes on Justice
League Origins that I did in four
minutes but he actually did do Justice
League origins in four minutes he just
has 46 other minutes of other stuff yeah
25 minutes
yeah but yeah it was it was it was fun
all right so all right so moving on um
are we are you guys ready to wrap up
Guardians of the Galaxy no we got to
keep talking dude you put you put us on
this Adam Warlock trip for like the last
30 minutes fine man my God talking about
the CH and you're like Adam Warlock had
a cocoon let's discuss people in the
comments love our tangents though oh I
know I know they're all just like hey
problem is they love the tangents but
they have to end eventually yeah
eventually they have to CL back in
otherwise it's like we're talking
Guardians of the Galaxy and more the
Cocoon and now we're on talking about
the Barbie that released in
1958 by the way dude I have that in my
collection um it's really nice worth a
lot of money now uh
anyway okay so we we discussed that
Easter egg um let's discuss Howard the
deck real quick what do you think this
means for the Universe I don't think it
means anything I think James Gunn or
Kevin Kevin fige or whoever it is said
that this is just the tip of the hat
like there's really not going to be any
expansion on how which I'm glad because
I mean come on the
CTIC I don't want to see a walking
talking duck no no no I don't think
we're going to get at Howard the Duck
comic a movie or a resurge into the
comic or anything but with this I what
this shows is Marvel is willing to do
anything out of the comics yep there is
no limit anymore Guardians of the Galaxy
was like a big what the hell are they
doing and then they end it with by the
way how would the duck also exists so
just go ahead and start picturing what
else we're throwing into this mix yeah
Howard the Duck sucks how Howard the
Duck does suck man he is such stupid C
was really bad in a movie with great CG
you had the PS which was supposed to set
up anything we wanted to see about
Marvel that could have been really cool
and we saw a really bad CG Howard the
Duck I'm sorry it was so bad I'm gonna
go ahead and say the last insulting the
last like three movies post credit
scenes have been so bad they've been the
worst like we had what that we had the
the therapist that was horrible the
therapist duck yes is saw cocon
congratulations Rob but it was about
Howard the Duck and his sucked yeah oh I
agree I agree Howard the Duck was Howard
Howard the Duck Howard the Duck was cool
like he was he was fun in the comics
because he was just weird it was weird
to see a walking talking duck going
around and fighting vampiric cows and
giant man frog like what do you do if
you Donald Duck in the cinema into a
Marvel universe that's pretty much the
whole concept behind Howard the Duck
yeah you can't do anything with that no
I I've been talking with people and I
think I I don't know maybe they'll
they'll put him in like cameos in the
future but they're not going to have him
have any like really important role like
they can't give him a full movie or even
like a full scene in a
movie just be ridiculous he gets cameos
right now throughout all of the like
every event how are the Ducks in the
background even original C he was in the
background so I would not doubt them
establishing him and then it becomes the
new game you know we had the stanlee
Cameo now it's going to be the Howard
the Duck did you catch Howard the Duck
Right see yeah that' be funny I mean I I
don't think it'd be very funny I mean
Howard the Duck is Howard the duck's
just a dumb character I'm sure that Seth
Green voicing Howard the Duck will
probably do a really good job but
honestly like it's it's not a matter of
of my concern that Howard the Duck may
take away from like the story or
anything like that it's just I don't
care about Howard the Duck
no like I did a Howard the Duck video
because I knew that after the movie came
out people were going to want to know
about Howard the Duck people were like
all right I want to know more about
Howard the Duck like 1986 okay whatever
and people can read some obscure stuff
people like what's this whole deal with
the controversy between Disney and
Marvel and people had sent me like
mountains and mountains of messages ask
me to do Howard the Ducks I was like
okay we'll go ahead and do a video on
him I mean sure you know he sucks but
whatever right yeah know I mean yeah
sucks I mean well nobody wanted to read
his Comics they wanted you to explain
him yeah yeah oh wow so so Howard the
Duck is confirm for Avengers
3 oh my God what did I tell you what did
I it's gonna be it's gonna be the new
because Stanley's getting too old to
keep doing this and we need something
that people are gonna look for and go
that's awesome I mean Stan Stan Lee he's
he's almost done with all his living
like he's getting pretty old all all of
his living I mean he's he's getting
pretty old dude she's going a live
like 200 just to spite you and make you
eat your words yeah yeah Rob at Marvel
explain said that I'm almost done with
all my well I'll show
him using the magic of myself
yeah because honestly we're running into
a problem where we're going to lose
Captain America we're going to lose you
know Iron Man we're going to lose these
actors soon we're going to lose the
Stanley camea yeah and I guarantee you
there was probably a meeting where they
sat around and said look Stan's getting
old you know he's almost done
living he's almost done with all his
living he's almost done with all of his
life so we need to look for someone else
that we can kind of start making funny
cameos with who's a great Cameo
character in the Marvel Universe and
they probably first said Deadpool and
then they said we don't own him and then
they went well Howard the Duck they
might have actually asked Stan he might
have said like oh Howard the Duck would
be kind of fun like Howard the Duck I
like how you have like that New York
accent with Howard the Duck how would
the duck how Duck's cool how would the
duck is going to be awesome I mean okay
sure like how would the duck show up or
to have like Thanos lay waste of the
planet Earth and then have like this
10sec scene where how the duck is like
wow I didn't see that coming or
something like that some goofy line that
would be cool all right that' just be
comedic relief but I don't want to see
Howard the Duck anything more than like
30 seconds in any given film at any Stan
Lee is Stan Lee doesn't never normally
exceed 10 seconds yeah but the fact that
the fact that Kevin fige is saying like
he's going to be in Avengers 3 I mean to
say like he's going in this movie
instead of saying he's just going to
have cameos and all these what would you
do Universe if an Avengers 3 they're
losing the Thanos and then Howard the
Duck shows up and saves I'm I'm gonna
I'm GNA say how in God's name is that
possibly gonna happen Rob is gonna be
like I'm done watching the Marvel I give
up Marvel's over time to go to DC y I'm
I'm I swear to God if that happens if
like Howard the Duck just jumps in and
like punches Thanos and it's just long
enough to distract him or something and
then like like the superhero come back
and win I'm going to be like okay like
I'm done with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe got I got a better do what if
we discover Howard the Duck was in the
Cocoon and that's our Adam
Warlock Rob will die
life we're just gonna call him Adam
Warlock I'd be so mad I'd be so pissed
like I would be like this this is like
i' probably throw my drink at the movie
screen scream Boo and walk out of the
theater I'd be so upset G just gonna
have him in like a white robe like
leading people through the desert oh
dude yelling at Stones yelling at rocks
like I would I would I would come back
and probably go on like a 30 minute rant
on my YouTube channel just like yelling
at Marvel like what the hell's wrong
with you like like in what Universe
would anybody believe that this would be
a good idea you know and just like
we know Marvel's going to start having
the Microsoft syndrome where when they
came out with Xbox One Microsoft was
like you all love Xbox right we're
Unstoppable so yeah we're not g to let
you do used games we're gonna do crazy
drms we're gonna everything you God and
then and then you know Xbox one came out
and they and now they're behind Wii U
but that's besides the point dude that's
a we could do we can do Howard the Duck
as Adam Warlock it'll work yeah like the
Sidetrack for a second from like comic
books in general like that's the one
reason I never bought an Xbox One and
it's the reason why I never will I'm
trading mine in on a side not I'm tra we
have an Xbox One on a PS4 and we play
that PS4 so much and the only exclusives
on the Xbox that we care about is Halo 5
which is like a year and a half out yeah
we are literally going to go trade in
that Xbox One to get another PS4 so that
we can uh do fire teams on Destiny nice
awesome yeah but um this guy Jeff said
Warlock the
duck Warlock the duck I like that um
warlock duck okay okay okay so so with
guardians gxy hold on I got I'm move to
another topic I I'll keep us rolling
with this Guardian stuff that's what I
was going to say like let's transition
to yeah let's get out of how the duck
now okay so the next question is I want
your guys opinions on how do you feel
about them hiding star-lords dad so much
and implying that it's an ancient race
that no one seen a while because if he's
if he's the the king of Spar talks yeah
they're gonna drop that you think
they're not gonna do it yeah no Marvel
said no huh go ahead there's no element
gun the element gun was replaced by by a
tape what I was so that's what I was so
upset about is there was no element gun
I was like come on like where's El but
you guys are getting way too caught up
with all this Fringe stuff that they
could by all means do in the future well
and Dave's right and that's I was going
to say about the element gun you guys
are getting all caught up in the element
gun and stuff like that but at the same
time we also need to not have super
complicated stuff making Star-Lord have
the element gun linked to his dad his
dad dropped him off that that
complicates the story but if we find out
his dad and this is where my question is
what think about it this way what in an
uncomplicated manner could we say is his
dad well that's that's what Marvel's
saying like they're saying that that his
dad in the movie is not going to be the
same as it was in the comics yeah it's
not Jason so it's so the question is
like who is it going to be and they
could easily shoehorn other characters
like Adam Warlock Adam Warlock they
could do a multitude of any other
character and say what if Adam Warlock
was his dad what if Thanos was his dad
cuz cuz they've implied that he's of a
race that can handle the infinity gems
he's not that race in the comics yeah no
oh um somebody asked if they missed a
Beta Ray Bill discussion so we'll have
to talk about Beta Ray Bill here in a
little bit but um show up do what did he
show up yeah where I
W where was that Easter because I
definitely R Bill R Bill's Easter egg
when you first walk into this is how I
know that Howard the Duck isn't Adam
Warlock when you
first when they first go to the uh to
the Watcher's cell or I'm sorry to his
uh not the Watcher the uh the
collector's Hangout out yeah yeah like
they first go in there like there's like
this this great big huge like like I
don't know maybe like 90° turn or
whatever is there's a there's a turn and
there's like this great big huge room
out on the side and then as The Watcher
is like walking towards them like up
above there is a character standing in a
giant cage there's a hammer sitting on
the ground and he's wearing a red cape
and then you actually see Howard the
Duck leaning up against his cage like
leaning up against the wall inside of
his thing
now like it's like Marvel's not I mean
there's not giant purple letter sitting
over Beta Ray Bill's cage saying this is
Beta Ray Bill but the fact that there's
like a hammer looking weapon and a guy
in a red cape standing there indicates
that it's probably beta rill so yeah
which is cool because bet Ray Bill is
badass so how would they explain that I
I I doubt well I actually even see bet
bill in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
they're just
like I think is too comical to just
bring into the Universe I I don't think
he's too comical but you're I mean if
you want to bring bring Beta Ray Bill
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
you've got to break down a fight between
him and Thor You' got to talk about
Thor's Ultra ego Donald Blake you've got
to talk about creating storm
breaker yeah it it gets too complicated
yeah that's that's why I wouldn't be
upset if there was no Beta Ray Bill
because I mean all Beta Ray Bill would
do is establish that other people
besides Thor can wield his hammer but
Captain America can do that later on so
it's this is what I imagine Marvel doing
with with all these Fringe characters
that they're kind of hinting at is we're
going to have eventually in either
Avengers 2 or the next Guardians of the
Galaxy movie or Avengers 3 that there's
going to be like some giant like space
battle that involves all of the Marvel
Universe making a Last Stand and they're
going to have all of these characters in
an army that mounts to face this thing
game of there pausing the scene going R
Bill power the duck that's exactly
what's GNA happen when the D when the
Blue-ray comes out yeah when the
Blue-ray comes out I know I will like
I'm gonna pause that and be like all
right like I'm I'm gonna lean up against
like lean against my chair crack my and
be like let's
see I think we need to assume everything
that's being hinted at unless it's a
post-credit scene is just potentially an
Easter egg and that's the extent of it
oh yeah I guarantee it's that's all it
is it's just an Easter egg and and I'm
not surprised that that's all it is just
an Easter egg because again it's not
like yeah I mean bill is a cool
character
but yeah like all bet Ray Bill does
again is just tell us that that other
what would you do tomorrow they're like
Beta Ray Bill Beta Ray Bill movie 2015
oh I would it I would freak I'd be like
yeah I want to see some
carites I would see that I mean I
wouldn't freak out but I'd be like
that's cool I'm going yeah I trust them
I TR I like they know what they're doing
I would see any movie that Marvel puts
out at this point at least once yeah but
at the same time they can't put like 20
movies out a year and have everybody go
to watch them so they've got to they've
got to you know set up their story lines
and pick their their important
characters to feature in in movies yeah
they can't make a Howard the Duck movie
and a Beta Ray Bill movie and an Adam
Warlock they're rich they could make
them all if they really wanted to but
yeah but but I'm
nobody's going to like come out and say
oh Disney Disney is going to make this
movie that they're going to spend $170
million on and it's only going to make
90 they're not going to do that I mean
because nobody's GNA go in and see a
banner for
Marvel's uh Beta Ray Bill and no they
don't know who Beta Ray Bill is I'm
going to build off of what uh Gabriel
says in the chat and say and like not
necessarily what he suggested where he's
like we should do they should do an MCU
animated series that like actually
follows the Canon but they should do
like an a what they did at DC with a DCU
animated Canon Universe where they kind
of like play with the universe a little
bit but like make it in Canon and like
throws Easter eggs and stuff like you
could have like in Justice League
Unlimited they had like the the cowboy
guy and and like the Knight guy they had
their own episode like you have a
Booster Gold episode in that show like
they need to do like that they need to
get and they had it with Earth's
Mightiest Heroes and they ruined it when
they canel all those shows and replaced
them with crappy shows but like we need
to have directed either directed DVD
animated shows or animated movies that
follow the Canon that set that are set
in the same universe or a good
comprehensive cartoon like Marvel show
well it's the same problem DC's having
they're they're all doing they're all
imply that they're in the same universe
but they're not at the same time DC's
doing the same crap with all their stuff
you know oh arrow and Flash are in the
same universe but are they really you
know well yeah and they're not in the
movie Universe they're only in their
show universe and like even with the
with the with the directed DVD movies
like The after Justice League War or
whatever like after the dumb New 52
reboot movie like the movies they're
making after that are in that universe
or in that continuity so like that's
what Marvel should be doing well and
they kind of have with like Avengers
Confidential
yeah but two of them and one of them
sucks like yeah Adventures confidential
was absolute crap like I I hated the
Black Widow Punisher one was good no I
lik I enjoyed it it was very it
screamed like it screamed animated me
and I don't by the way not like I hate
anime I'm just saying like you hate
anime yeah exactly crucify me on the
internet but like uh I felt like no like
the uh Avengers Confidential like Black
Widow Punisher was cool it had like
peripheral characters that you would
never expect to see in a movie like that
or in a Marvel movie um but it also was
very like it was that studio like that
that Japanese Studio made that movie and
they told it the way they wanted to tell
it we need like a guy who's in charge
who isn't uh the guy in charge of Marvel
TV right now who's awful Jeff lobe like
someone who's not Jeff lobe somebody
like slot or somebody like uh Remer no I
I agree because we we could fully
explore all of these other characters in
the cartoon series easily you could do a
how the duck animated movie we could
incorporate Spider-Man into the universe
because they have the animated rights oh
my God I don't I you know what I really
disagree I'm I'm I like people are
driving me nuts talking about let's
bring Spider-Man into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe why not why because
Spider-Man is the most overrated
character in the history of comic book
characters all but he needs to be there
Spider-Man Spider-Man shoots webbing out
of his hands or out of his wrist all
right he
swings from object to object and he can
punch really hard like Spider-Man is a
criminally overrated character oh no he
not that at all like I don't think he's
that great of a character I don't really
think he's I mean he has important
storylines because Marvel know he knows
he's popular but at the same time his
power set like he he goes and he fights
with the Avengers and and you know out
in outer space and he's in all sorts of
like Marvel events where he's way
outclassed yeah this is why cuz every
time we see Avengers who's on the same
merchandising block who's in the front I
mean for the most part anytime you see
Marvel you'll see you'll see I mean
Spider-Man's a face of Marvel which I
understand I mean Spider-Man is a Legacy
character he revamped the concept of
superheroes and comic books and that
much I I get but for me like I just
don't think Spider-Man's that great by
the way good story so far just everyone
he's kind of like Batman in a way
because Batman doesn't have
superpowers but he manages to pull off
some crazy amazing thing that saves
everybody sometimes like
yeah I don't know
other like like this guy is like like Fu
Rob Spider-Man is awesome no he's
not now Spiderman's awesome I'm not
saying that he's a bad character I read
look this look at this merchandizing
right here Avengers Iron Man and a
Spider-Man backpack I'm not saying
Spider-Man's not popular I'm saying in
the grand scheme of superheroes that
we've seen Spider-Man's just not that
great he's really agile and he's strong
and Rob I believe this is the end of our
friendship um and we are done so s let's
go let's go make the weekly the weekly
poll podcast too let's call the spider
pole I'm gonna go I'm gonna go take a
nap all Spider-Man all the time ex but
no I mean speaking of that next week we
need to discuss spiderverse so Rob go
buy some freaking Spider-Man comics I I
mean I'll read Spider-Man if you guys
really want me to SP not that on
Spider-Man spider spiderverse
spiderverse I don't read Spider-Man or
anything I don't really even have
anything to like it's like Wolverine
like I usually never read Wolverine I I
read Spider-Man I I like Rob will not be
here next week everyone um d s
discussing spiderverse I mean most most
of my comic book reading involves well
right now it involves the century which
I love Robert Reynold's character the
Paul Jenkins Jay run of Marvel Knights
Century volume one is amazing well hold
on what am I getting why am I getting
the shaken
head you think that Spider-Man is
overrated but the Sentry is a cool
character and this this gu hold on hold
on we got Rob's viewers here and I'll
don't even ask them Rob this Rob came to
the other day and Rob was like what
should I do next and I'm like Rob maybe
you should stop doing the Obscure
characters like Howard the
Duck okay R so so I'm going to set
something up for for you that that that
might convince you otherwise okay I just
read secret Invasion okay and pretty
much the scr's solution to taking out
the
Sentry was basically manipulating his
crazy mhm yeah like they literally just
said hey uh the scrolls are all here
invading Earth because you kind of
wished it and he doesn't even have that
power like like he doesn't have the
power to wish things into existence but
he was like oh God I'm crazy I got to go
like oh no it's all my fault then he
goes away I mean actually kind of does
Rob I figured you out what I figured Rob
out guys you are a comic book hipster if
a character if a character is popular
you don't like them if they're obscure
you love them there are a lot of there
are a lot of popular characters that I
that I love you just announced Wolverine
Spider-Man and Batman in a 5 minute
discussion yeah yeah but yeah but I I
love the the character of The Incredible
it's cool can you show up in a flannel
outfit next week that says go
Century can prove this Theory very
easily watch this watch this uh who is a
more interesting character see see
they're calling you a Marvel hipster
before this the thing catches up what
whatever whatever okay what did you say
oh who's the more interesting character
blackbolt or
Wolverine nobody's gonna say but he
knows the no who is more interesting who
is a cooler character blackbolt because
he can he can never talk because he can
never talk he boring as crap he doesn't
that's why he's boring Rob just because
the character has a cool
complex I was just kidding like the
reality is like it's up to you like it's
all your opinion like so that's fair the
chat is blowing up about how you don't
like Wolverine and Spider-Man Rob
Wolverine okay okay you know here's
here's Wolverine all of your viewers are
turning on you Mar's Wolverine in like
two sentences all right I'm Wolverine I
don't know why I'm here I'm going to
kill people that's Wolverine in every
story ever in the history of Marvel
Spider-Man's almost the exact same thing
I'm Spider-Man I don't know why I'm
here yeah that's that's it man like like
wolver rain is just like wolver rain is
a pointless character like he's just not
at all important wolver was
best Christopher FR says and you don't
read DC case close you're a
hipster no like like the the best the
best wolver rain that had ever been seen
is one Old Man Logan which was pretty
good in terms of like some of the
stories like I've read a few of Old Man
Logan and two is horrible and and two
like Chris claremont's run of the X-Men
like that's that's when wol rain was
interesting the most let me ask you this
if next year you hear that a Century
movie is coming out will you still back
Century
yes because because okay no because
because Robert Reynolds okay and this
and we'll talk about this when we do our
when we do our video on the century
Robert Reynolds is interesting all right
Robert Reynolds is he's crazy and he's a
schizophrenic like he can't
differentiate between what's real and
what's not and he's got multiple
personalities the void is this super
stupid powerful character that fought
off a contingent a full contingent of
the Avengers the Inhumans A Fantastic
Four and the X-Men at the same time like
it took Emma Frost convincing Robert
Reynolds who had retreated into his own
mind that the void was his Creation in
order to stop it like he's a really cool
character and I I love that element
that you've got a guy and no one knows
whether he's sane or not who has this
just crazy amount of power in Marvel
Comics like that's why I love his
calling you a name dropping hipster
right
now I for the record I'm supposed to be
the guy that reels us back into the
Guardians of the Galaxy toic but I am
all four calling rob a hipster and all
of us bashing him everybody call me a
hipster man so I was I was actually
thinking for a
versus you guys doing the Sentry versus
Superman because I knew the Sentry was
totally strong enough that's fine but
it'd be a very hipster fight it would be
it would be I used to read the C back
before he was F but no like like in all
seriousness though like like go and read
go and read Marvel Knights from 2000 the
year 2000 read Marvel Knights Paul
Jenkins Jay Le's run of the century it's
a five isue self-contained story it
introduces and closes out the century
which they obviously bring him back in
New Avengers but it's one of the best
stories you're ever going to read in
Marvel like it's it's such a good series
of
books yeah Franklin Richard would
absolutely destroy the void that's true
I don't know either one of them
are but but nonetheless yeah it's it'd
be cool it's it's okay Rob I've been
called a bandwagoner because I made I
made a um when I first launched the
channel and I was mimicking the eligible
monster program lineup of top sixes and
stuff like that I did a top six things I
didn't know about the X-Men when days
future pass came out and I learned quite
a few interesting things because I don't
look up random obscure facts about the
X-Men and like half of the comments are
did uh I already knew all this you're
just a bandwagoner because the movie
came out I'm reading Xmen probably when
you were still in diapers but hey
whatever you know whatever man I me
reading X-Men does not tell me that that
mutant is an actual race for the toys
sake and yeah like I was like I know
enough about X-Men to know that Jubilee
was created two years before the
Animated Series came out so just say I
know Mor is not in the comics so that's
actually uh um what is his name man the
guy that that um can copy the like when
he first shows up when they first
introduced him he had the feet of Beast
he had the wings of angels the eyes of
Cyclops yeah that's mimic mimic there we
go yes mimic that that was like the
standin for Morphin he suck anim series
he does suck man like he's an awful Char
he then like they never brought him back
I think showed up in like Exiles yeah he
was he was a terrible character there's
a lot of there is a lot of X-Men who
just randomly pop up like look this one
can pee lemonade try it I mean he's
there's there's some there's some
characters that aren't that are like
super powerful but they never really Ed
them that much like elixir like elixir
was cool because he could heal people
and heal himself and he could like
adjust the molecules in his body but
like aside from that like there comes a
point where he makes himself gold and
it's like okay I mean there was an there
was an X-Man who could learn
languages oh yeah there's one that could
like understand any language there was
one also that that could just make fake
gold
balls out of his body in a totally
different direction we have like we're
we're totally off on tangents to like
okay I was gonna say we've been going
for a little while now um I've actually
got to get running in about 10 minutes
so okay let's let's wrap it up well I
guess we're going on without
Benny aren we already at i' I've got an
hour and 45 minutes Rob even taking out
our 20 minute verses yeah yeah we've
been going for a while okay so so then
then I guess we we'll uh we'll do um
we'll do in humans next week but um
nonetheless like like yeah I I thought I
thought Guardians into the Galaxy for
for a movie that was based on a Marvel
character it's a Marvel group takes
place within the Marvel Universe was a
great movie because it didn't feel like
a Marvel film and I also thought it was
really good because what it does is it
takes all the events that have taken on
taken place on planet Earth and it
Compares them to like all these
Interstellar events going on and you're
like who cares about
Shield like who cares about what's going
on on planet Earth so that's exactly
what happens in the comics when you're
dealing with like oh yeah a Universal
scale event is they're they like the
humans end up whining about all this
stuff that's happened to them and
they're like that's nothing no idea like
you you have no idea we've had like six
planets get blown up in the last month
yeah this is very true and we have
incursions happening every day one of
s's most favorite events
ever I just I just saw your back issues
that's why I've been picking on you
thank watch yeah because we T we were
like we talk about Infinity Gauntlet and
I talk for like 15 minutes about the
incursions because like cap destroys The
Infinity Gauntlet to try and put them
away yeah I mean that's that that's
something that I'm really looking
forward to is seeing like the whole you
know Infinity Gauntlet storyline taking
place and whatnot but um yeah but no you
know like I said I thought it was it was
a it was a great film it was a great
film that you could go into knowing
nothing about any characters knowing
nothing about any of these individuals
and still have like like the time of
your life watching like a really fun
hilarious film which I I really enjoyed
agreed yeah and I I loved it for that
the I think there was only one moment in
the entire movie that I was just kind of
like all right can we get get to the
next scene of something cuz are you
doing yeah yeah it was it was it was
pretty cool the way they overall I loved
every minute of it um I I had no issues
no complaints the movie was great uh I
liked it more than turtles turtles every
time megga Fox talked I was like un
Turtles I haven't seen Turtles yet you
guys all got to go get SE Turtles so we
can talk about it next week I'm I'm man
you have to I'm sorry I'm not going to
spend money seeing that movie not that
bad you just just close your eyes and
Megan Fox talks I'll buy it when it's $5
on Blu-ray but until then yes I I'll
purchase the movie I enjoyed it am I the
only and I'm not the only one by the way
every other five-year-old in this world
love that yeah I mean it's it's a it's
cool like Ninja Turtles have always been
kind of fun to me but you know like
Ninja Turtles 2 secret of the use as far
as I'm concerned is the best it'll ever
be oh no yeah you're right never be that
good again hold wait wait wait wait have
you seen it s has shaking his head you
seen it like within the last 20 years
because I saw it last year and it's
freaking horrible no under no
circumstances is ninja
secret it is horrible no sir they can't
use their weapons they they don't have B
by Rock Steady it's it's RI Lane
characters Kino is the main character
they replace the good April there's no
Casey Jones they defeat Shredder with a
guitar that's so lame yes but it has
super you have you he for a half second
and then he kills
himself call Nostalgia goggles yeah I by
the way that said Ninja Turtles one is
the tits no sir no sir Ninja Turtles no
Ninja turt anyone seen the Ninja Turtles
cartoon where the new anime Ninja
Turtles met up with the 1980s Ninja
Turtles and the it is a great show it is
mindbending it is because they meet up
with the original Turtles and they act
just like the original Turtles and the
new like anime Turtles are like what are
these guys doing why do they care so
much about pizza yep it is amazing wow
yeah um this guy Havoc Cyclops is
spamming the chat saying that Loki is
star-lords
Dad I'll be so pissed if that turns out
to be the case I would
such an easy way out it's just it's such
a cop out like uh around we'll just make
Loki the
dad I thought at the end the way they
they wrapped it up with uh I forget his
name the blue guy that that controls the
arrow yond he was like oh it's a good
thing we didn't bring him to his
dad yeah we didn't take him to L I like
it's a good thing we didn't take him to
his dad that guy's a
dick by the way yandu was cool just
going to go and record y grew up y was
awesome well he was a great charact yeah
he's always been a great Char oh I need
this I just found a Rocket Raccoon and
Groot statue oh nice nice I saw somebody
on Etsy was selling a Groot that you put
in a pot like where it's like little
dancing group he doesn't move but you
put him in a pot and there he is oh
they're gonna sell like grou Chia Pets
oh yeah why would why aren't they on
sale now yeah I would buy one right now
I hear the special edition Blu-ray from
from Amazon when when they get the whole
pre-order thing with Disney figured out
is is going to have a dancing
Groot smart okay well I I think I think
we're about as far off topic as we can
get at this point
so talking about Groot um all right so
to uh so to wrap the podcast up what
does everybody have going on in the next
couple weeks or so on their
channels um I am launching um an amazing
story a story of time travel a story of
Doctor Who Batman in time
come it comes out like
Saturday it comes out Saturday and I'm
also going to do the colors of Hulk I
figured that since the Green Lantern
colors are doing so well explain why
there's 90,000 colors of the Hulk God
there are man I mean the three most
prominent ones you got red Hulk Gray
Hulk and uh the green Hulk so right
right but then there's also red She Hulk
green She Hulk there's also uh World War
Hulk there's various versions of Hulk
that because apparently looking this up
each version of Hulk is a shade of green
m h so there's like light green Hulk
dark green Hulk forest green Hulk yeah
World War Hulk was just like really
pissed off Hulk like he stomped in the
ground and shook the entire Eastern
Seaboard like that that was such a cool
Point like there like the the one the
coolest Parts on World War Hulk is when
century when the century shows up and
like when he when he takes only hipster
guys know that guy and he says he says
he says it's time to play God and I was
like that's awesome yeah that it was a
cool it was a cool fight book it was it
was a really cool really cool thing we
didn't get to talk about yandu Havoc
Cyclops so you shut up
what what are we going to talk about
yandu he was really cool he was blue and
I don't know what that weapon was but it
was really Nifty with the whistling I
mean that was pretty badass like I wish
I had one of those I am going to do
spiderverse when that wraps up
Christoper I'm actually going to be
hitting up uh eventually I'm doing big
time I'm going to start the dance slot
run over the next month my plans are to
hit up some more Guardians of the Galaxy
but I'm doing blackest Knight I'm doing
the war of the lanterns I'm doing Batman
rest in peace Batman in time um and I'm
doing uh Spider-Man big time onward
awesome that'll be cool Spider-Man big
time got me back into Spider-Man after I
quit from one more day that's what I
heard I got a lot of people back into
Spider-Man it was good I have mine mine
is signed by Stanley and Dan lot so oh
wow so what you got coming up
Benny I am Benny s oh
s not know
name damn it
Dave
um so what I've got going on as usual uh
Monday through Wednesday we have our
individual comic book review show off
the rack where we take one book and
review it and of course the the the hint
or the the hitch is two of the guys that
I work with Ben and Ethan don't normally
read Comics so they give their kind of
Outsiders non-comic readers perspective
and uh off the rack is cool because we
also judge the book based on just the
content between the covers we don't we
try not to like tie it in we want to see
like if this would be one comic we just
grab off the rack and we read it would
it be enough to get us to read more
would it be is it a good comic on it on
its own uh so that's the idea of off the
rack we we do that Monday through
Wednesday Thursday's of course is back
issues we just did a we just did a uh a
poll where we had the reader or the
viewers decide what EP or what book we
were going to do and our options were
Siege secret War not Secret Wars but
secret war and JLA versus Avengers and
it looks like Siege W by one vote wow I
don't like that I voted wow you did
votee was a great story though Siege was
cool so I'm happy to talk about it so
this week which is today we will be
shooting the new back issues which will
have the fan generated uh book that
we're going to review and Monday and
then usually Wednesday through Friday I
put out a another show called tangents
where it's like all the stuff we did in
this podcast but I rip them from uh back
issues just to keep the the length and
back issues kind of of manageable while
also not losing these amazing like
tangents that go off the rails yeah so
that's what we're doing weekly five days
a week we have we have new content nice
nice wait before Rob goes into his I
want to State one thing everyone's like
oh you guys need to reschedule for the
record I'm the scapegoat we go for two
hours and I just conveniently have to go
guys true I mean like we would love fors
and hours and hours we have sat down and
discussed should we make four or five
hour podcast but the fact of the matter
is it just gets into everyone's way that
way yeah yeah like it'd be awesome the
viewers the viewers don't want to sit
there for while including the viewers
yeah we have 50 of you and we had 80 a
half hour ago yeah I know a few of you
guys want us to just go endlessly but
the fact of the matter is two hours is a
good stopping point because at this
point we've either gone a completely
wild tangent yep or we've beaten a topic
to death yeah yeah
exactly and and for discussion next time
around too so the four of us are going
to talk after we get
done but um the only way we could do
four hours is if we did the Q&A thing
like we did last time oh which we need
to do again that was we we should do
that again yeah totally that was good
anyway Rob didn't we say like every
other week we were gonna do that I
thought we try to do it once a month
every other week yeah keep that guys
keep that in mind guys like once a month
that probably be like the last I guess
like the last Thursday every month will
it probably be the week that none of us
thought of a topic probably yeah like
we'll uh we'll just do like a live Q&A
session where you guys can ask questions
and and we'll answer them so um but but
yeah so um the century will be coming
out on Monday uh we're going to have
that video finished by then or at least
we should um after that we'll be doing
William Striker um after William Striker
we'll get into Gan gray which I know a
lot of you guys have been asking about
Jean Gray we'll get into like a lot of
the a lot of the characters from the
X-Men so like Gambit stuff like that
like we'll get into a lot of those
characters that you guys have been like
screaming at me about about wanting um
somebody wanted like actually I think
I've had a few people that have wanted
me to do the one above all so I mean he
appears in like 15
Comics like hey guys uh there's this
like God of the Marvel Universe
sometimes it's Jack Kirby thanks for
watching
peace I I have a former request that
you're the Obscure guy and I can't even
get information on this guy what I want
a full explanation of what the builders
are yeah man let me tell you something
if you didn't learn about the builders
in the infinity or in Infinity then
you're not going to know because that's
like that's as far as I know that's the
only time the builders ever referenced
or I no Hickman invented them they don't
they they've been around since the new
Marvel Now Avengers one they were the
first villain to be introduced really so
explain them explain them man I'll
try they're the primary villain of the
current Avengers run and I've been
trying to figure them out and I'm like
how are they different from the
celestials aren't they the same freaking
thing but I mean they're they are
obscure as hell the celestials the
celestial were the ones that created
mutants and so on and so forth so it was
weird because it was like if you're GNA
do a a universe changing character like
why just use the celestials yeah like
why you got to invent something new like
especially that is literally literally
the same as the as the celestial yeah
well that's that that's why like that's
why I like T's run of the Fantastic Four
like Future Foundation like the Mad
Celestial show up yeah and they merge
themselves in like one big Mega
Celestial and like like almost destroy
Galactus so and the [__] what by the way
uh I I am planning on within the next
couple months getting that that run now
after you've talked about it a couple
times which one nice FF Future
Foundation oh yeah Future Foundation is
so good dude Hickman's running the
Fantastic for it's probably the best
fantastic for it's in the Hickman
Omnibus for for fantastic for there's
two volumes and for those figure that's
going to be a great run to get into the
Fantastic Four with so yeah for those of
you guys who were like who were in the
chat like like there are a handful of
writers that are always amazing when it
comes to Marvel Comics like Paul Jenkins
is good at pretty much everything like
the like Paul Jenkins involvement in
Marvel Knights so like 1998 Inhumans the
century like those are some of the
awesome like some of the best stories
you ever going to read um Hickman's
entire run on the Fantastic 4 is like
incredible I mean there's there's some
really really good writers out there I'm
really sad that they're getting rid of
the Fantastic like they're shuffling
them to the Wayside now they are man
they really shouldn't I've heard
Marvel's doing that because of the whole
Fox rights and all that kind of stuff
yep that's it so sucks Dave do you have
anything coming out this week I know I
know you just get back in your feet I
just gota I just got to finish up the
videos I've decided to do all seven
parts of of my uh my Civil War at once
so I'm in the middle of like editing and
putting Motion Graphics together and
everything for that so
like today I'm I'm going to have one to
two videos out or like tomorrow
morning one two videos I know I give you
a hard time it's just com oh I know I
know and you try to motivate me which I
appreciate yeah yeah sure it's
motivation okay so before we close out
though I have one question now that s
has moved his head a
little behind you there is what appears
to be a w wooden dildo with the angle
that it's currently at no
there wow what is that sound it's a it's
a piece of Driftwood that my dad likes
it looks like a natural Arch that's a
form the formation from uh from coery
Italy okay good the angle that it's at
with the way that the camera's on it and
everything I was like if that is we need
to discuss soel not putting that stuff
out in the open yeah also
wood exactly I was like it looks lters
yeah no it is it is a piece of Driftwood
that my dad like found and he was like
oh this like my dad likes to do no it
looks cool at all just like I said from
the angle and once you moved your head I
was like whoa
whoa I'm glad you pointed it out I'll
move
that no yeah wait my my dad and I share
an office so it's I was I was wondering
why all that stuff was back there I was
like do you have like a yeah it's not my
stuff my stuff's that way I look at I I
can when I look that way all my stuff's
over here okay see this is you're
actually in my space that's that's my
exotical candy my wife's space for
working and everything over there yeah
exactly and this is the recording TV
which is set up to play The Silent Hill
trailer after this nice nice yeah I'm
I'm really psyched for the new Silent
Hill yes as I said
that yeah like my girlfriend is not oh
your girlfriend your girlfriend's not
excited for the new Silent Hill my
girlfriend is a huge Silent Hill buff
she loves Silent Hill one two and three
and then that is and that's where it
stops They're bringing back the original
Japanese on the on the new ones cool
it's got hideo kajima he's the director
yeah yeah I had seen that it's got GMO
doroo and Norman Reedus is the main
character yes that's what I'm the most
excited about is Norman Reus Y and those
are some big names in movies
yeah now we're gonna have an hour
discussion with silent hill
so well all you guys that uh wanted a
three-hour pod guess we're going to
shift to games real quick shift to video
games um all right guys well I mean if
nobody else has anything going on then I
guess we'll call it a night yeah
everyone's yell at me for for am I am I
really the only one who saw that and
thought
that what's wrong with you Ben what's
your problem Oh I'll also mention uh
really quick uh today our new back
issues is on The Infinity Gauntlet yes
nice and it's really good and I totally
missed out on my Batman and Time video
but it's going to be better now because
I'm going to do Doctor Who theme songs
you have to I make sure I check that out
yeah all right guys well uh yeah I think
we're going to go and bring it to an end
so all right thank you everybody and I
don't know why I'm I'm not the one that
has to turn everything off
so we'll catch you guys later peace see
you all
right did you see them they were all
yelling at me because I because I had
they're like Benny always has to go you
guys need to reschedule to do it without
him like it's been two
hours yeah I have to agree with you I
mean we get off on tangents and we lose
track of time and then it just I I I
mean I could go it just devolves into
just garbage I could easily reschedule a
bunch of stuff if we wanted to really do
for our podcast but i' i' like we have
to take like a lunch break and crap in
the middle right like I normally get up
and I take my shower and I get ready and
then I have like a snack yeah well
that's that's all I've had to